let's jump to the big news story it
really breaks my heart
the national review reports the times
corrects the record
on officer sicknick's death sort of the
gist of the story
the officer who lost his life it was an
unrelated stroke they say
a few days ago the new york times
quietly quietly updated its report
published over a month earlier asserting
that capital police officer brian
sicknick
had been killed by being struck with a
fire extinguisher during the january 6
riot
according to the update quote new
information has emerged regarding the
death of the capitol police officer
brian siknik
that questions the initial cause of his
death provided by officials close to the
capitol police
they say as i detailed in a column last
week what the times calls new
information
actually began emerging the same day the
paper filed its january 8th report more
importantly
they initially said law enforcement
sources now they're saying
officials close to the capitol police
what is that
muriel bowser the dc mayor could it be
like a homeless guy who's
next to the police department that's one
thing i always pointed out when they say
close to what does that even mean
well they say official i suppose so at
least somebody was working
they say that report was and still is
entitled capital police officer dies
from injuries in pro-trump rampage
it was not the only such times report
from that day there was another entitled
quote he dreamed of being a police
officer then was killed by a pro-trump
mob
in which the times assert asserted on
wednesday pro-trump supporters attacked
the citadel of democracy
overpowered mr sicknick 42 and struck
him in the head with a fire extinguisher
according to two law enforcement
officials with a bloody gash in his head
mr sikdik was rushed to the hospital and
placed on life support he died
on thursday evening but they mentioned
k-h-o-u
uh he reported he had died from a stroke
the story made no mention of the officer
being struck by a
fire extinguisher it did claim however
the stroke occurred at the capitol
during the riots
and a caption under the officer's
photograph stated that he died of
injuries sustained during the riot at
the capitol isn't amazing how they do
that
check this out we have the actual
article from khou-11
u.s capitol police officer on life
support dies
after suffering stroke following riots
union chair said
this is from january 8th how is how is
how
how i mean i got to be honest how did i
miss this i mean this story is old
yeah this was one of the big aspects of
the whole impeachment process
the officer who lost his life they did
this big event where they brought him
into the capitol building to lay him to
rest
should we be surprised by this no not at
all i mean the new york times went into
detail they talked about a bloody head
blunt
force trauma critical condition rushed
to the hospital
and now we're finding out all of that
what was what was that based on
absolutely nothing where's the
responsibility where's the
accountability
youtube [ __ ] facebook twitter go after
these people for knowingly spreading
fake news if you're going to apply this
against
you know the average joe your
independent media apply it to them
whenever there's anonymous sources i
always say there's always reason to be
skeptical
and they use anonymous sources there's
videos showing a fire extinguisher
flying around but
imagine being a reporter at the new york
times right and then just
totally fabricating this story i mean
they're talking about their two sources
who are their sources
you know there should be reviews they
should burn them right yeah their
sources
lie to them yeah so either they're okay
with that
being lied to about what's effectively
blood libel
right you're accusing a political
movement of murder well obviously
i have some breaking oh god or they did
what the mainstream media usually
usually does and they fabricate and make
up sources that are not there at all
so they do this a lot in the mainstream
media so go ahead i have breaking news
uh
uh it is now confirmed to me from a
source close to nancy pelosi's office in
san francisco that she is in fact a
fascist
who is uh you know selling us out to
massive corporations
and and she is personally
taking bribes from others close to her
office now this source
close to her office is a homeless guy in
the alley you know behind her building
and he seems to be a bit out of it you
know i think he's not getting his proper
medication you see the point i'm trying
to make
yeah if clever were obviously i don't
have any confirmation on nancy pelosi
being corrupt or whatever well actually
i mean
just read the news and you might come to
that conclusion the point i'm making is
this kind of stuff happens all the time
and the new york times lies all the time
and i i just
i it's funny that this story came out a
month and a half ago
and the new york times is only just now
updating it and it's not even admitting
fault it's just saying well there's
other
sources saying something different like
you would think that you'd be able to
confirm or deny
the story about him being the victim of
blunt force trauma that's either true or
it's not
and a month after his death we would
know the answer to that question the
crazy thing is
that i got to be honest i think i think
a lot of us missed this
i particularly missed it and it's
because we don't read local news
local news is hurting really bad their
their ad rates are drying up and people
are
sending their money to the new york
times so it really is true that we need
good journalists to help us understand
what's going on right now
well just going on in general and
because local news is suffering
more and more people want the national
story more and more people are attracted
to the orange man bad narrative
they ignore what's happening around them
then you have these smaller outlets
who actually reach out to the union find
out what really happened and how is it
that we've now gone
into an impeachment a month later with
this narrative
like when when they when they laid
officer siknik to rest in the capitol
it was well after it was reported he
just died from a stroke
so remember when this first happened and
we were talking about it and somebody in
the chat was like
he's actually not dead yet we're like he
has already died because that was what
was first reported was that he was gone
like as soon as this happened
and that right from the get-go it was
inconsistent what they were talking
about whether he was actually gone or
not and they couldn't make up their
minds
he was on life support yeah i mean this
is supposed to be the paper of record
if they if the journalist isn't willing
to burn their anonymous sources the
journalists should be fired
like i mean you're trying to i don't
know i mean it's just
it's it's it's we shouldn't be surprised
that the new york times is media matters
but like it still
is it still is actually kind of
infuriating that they can't even
maintain the pretense
another thing we have to understand here
this was a very important emotional
talking point we saw a lot of mainstream
media figures and also politicians talk
about the officer that was beat with a
fire extinguisher over its head until he
was
dead beat bloody with a fire
extinguisher over and over psychological
kind of uh you know operation some
people would
would say to push the bigger point that
look how horrible how evil these people
are when in reality they were they were
caught with their pants down they were
lying about this from the very beginning
and
if they're lying about this what else
are they lying about that's the bigger
question
americans should be asking themselves uh
but they're not they shouldn't be
trusted
and again i i point to again the big
social tech media companies they want to
combat
fight fake news fight it right now prove
them
give us an example of the mainstream
media actually getting a taste of their
own medicine
this is why it's so important that
parlor is coming back
because twitter suppresses news these
big tech giant suppress news i mean
twitter literally shut down the hunter
biden story and then
they they take down parlor with more
fake news so the big claim
when parlor got taken down was basically
that people were organizing on parlor
for the capital riot
and that was a lie so all of this
information coming out is a lie
yeah i mean we're being i mean the good
example there was facebook was far more
of the center of that sort of organizing
for january 6th
something like if you actually look at
the criminal indictments like 80 percent
of them mentioned organizing on facebook
there was plans online
yeah to go after the capital right
there's groups there's individuals
publicly talking about this and then
the intelligence agencies you know oh
you know we had no idea we had no clue
and then and then when it comes to the
inauguration huge massive security
theater
huge national guard because there is a
now now there is a legitimate threat
look look you got to give them some
credit
they may have dropped the ball this time
but i mean they've been particularly
diligent in doing their jobs like when
um
when the when the noose was found at the
nascar garage
they were there they wanted it and they
were yes absolutely uh well how many
were like over a dozen yeah
so you know when we need the most
they're there i mean who really cared
about
the capital right i mean you know well
there's other reports that i'm seeing
that trump actually requested
troops on that day and he was denied i
still haven't been able to independently
uh verify that's true
okay yeah so mayor muriel bowser said
she didn't
want a massive police presence when they
said they were going to bring in the
national guard
she said she didn't want them to be
armed there were other uh
individuals in you know dc politics
saying oh no
you know and and it may be that because
of black lives
matter and the optics around the police
coming and you know going after the
protesters
but they were guarding the white house
you know pretty diligently i mean
there was fences around the white house
weeks before uh
january 6th so you know something of
course a lot of people are asking a lot
of questions
especially with some of the people that
are arrested that had ties to the fbi
now i don't want to get all
conspiratorial because because again we
have no actual proof or evidence of this
you have a lot of conjecture you have a
lot of people you know connecting the
dots and certain issues but
i think it's fair to say that there
definitely should be a lot more
questions about this event
i i think it's pretty demoralizing man
you know i use the new york times
all the time and i generally give them
the benefit of the doubt
that when they're reporting something it
it's likely to be true not not
massively likely i'm not saying 99 but
at least come on 51
there's just like a banal awfulness for
our institutions right now i mean
you know rent said something about the
banality of evil i wouldn't call them
evil but
they're just awful they're like not the
banality of allah is the finality of
awfulness they're just
so bad at doing performing their basic
function
you know you know i mean they've been
bad though i wanna i wanna i wanna sit
here and play this whole like barry
weiss angle
you know if those aren't familiar she
worked for the time she wrote this big
letter when she left saying it's like
wokeness and critical theory and
intolerance taking over but the reality
is new york times has been awful for a
long time
i mean the iraq war you know it's just
less but it's gotten
worse i mean i think the example would
be like they broke the hillary clinton
email story
four years ago yeah you know they they
they were they published the snowden
articles when they came out during the
obama administration
there was i think i think there's two
dynamics one is you know trump made them
all
deranged and they became like partisan
as opposed to like just liberal but
trying to be you know trying to be
objective and then i think the second
thing is
you know you see all these woke scandals
in the new york times and i mean they're
so consumed by these internal hr dramas
that they've lost their ability to
perform their function of
being journalists they're constantly
writing about themselves
yeah that's the crazy thing there's like
another article that came out right now
about the new york times
and i can't remember who but one of
these media reporters ben smith was it
ben who was like the new york times has
has become like a reality show where
they're just writing articles about
their own staff members now
but people people are clicking it that's
why they're doing it well i remember a
few years ago hearing about their
investigative unit just being totally
gutted
by new acquisitions to the company and
that makes absolutely sense because if
you don't have the budget
to investigate stories or look into
stories or research stories
well you just have to make them up just
like they did in this instance and
and i think it's very fair to say that
this i mean
you could say evil you could say just
total ignorance you could just say total
stupidity
whether it is or isn't it's still
absolutely wrong
and bad and it needs to be called out as
much as it can so people realize that
the new york times is not the newspaper
of record
it's the newspaper of whatever special
interest or bozo behind it
uh no no it's the lowest common
denominator of subscribers
so they probably look at their
subscriber base the people who are
paying
you know digitally and they're like
which one's gonna you know attract more
people or
which one will be interesting to most of
the people who watch or you know who
read our stuff
and so you know i want to make sure that
we don't become
like the new york times we here at tim
castro which is why we're very seriously
looking into setting up a tv commercial
for our pillow
we're gonna we're gonna make sure that
we use our resources for important
things that's right like a burlap sack
full of packing peanuts that we
advertise on primetime cable
just as sort of like a culture jam you
know or whatever but
i'm kidding actually we are we are
working towards hiring reporters
and the idea would be the new york times
is going backwards that's the way i view
it
they're supposed to be using you know
all this all this
stuff they report on the funding they
get from subscribers should go
towards journalism that people probably
don't want to hear or might not care
about
instead what they're doing is they're
getting rid of the journalism that
people probably don't care about but
still need to be reported
and replacing it with internal drama and
conflict
what i want to do here is that we have
like we're all sitting here complaining
about the new york times we don't even
do
hardcore investigative journalism so
it's like easy for us to criticize
well we're going in the right direction
in that from a commentary podcast show
we're going to use funding towards
actual journalism
and that's kind of the idea i think
they're doing the opposite but look i'll
give them some respect in that
they do journalism although i'm pretty
concerned about whether i can trust it
at this point and i think you know what
we want to do is particularly different
we'll have a brand that literally only
does journalism so we're like we'll
create a website dedicated specifically
to
just reporting stuff and then we can
keep the commentary off of that
otherwise i don't know man i think it's
it's demoralizing
yeah it is there is something it's just
like you
you rely on there being some
institutions that remain
nonpartisan i think it's it's part of a
bigger theme think about like the aclu
for example
everybody was great with the aclu when
they were just always fight free speech
cases you knew that it didn't matter if
it was some communist
or some terrible white nationalist
whatever it was if they were having
their free speech rights violated the
aclu would go in and defend them
because they were like the principal
matters more it's about the right now
they don't do that
now they turn down far-right clients yup
because they're uncomfortable with it
um well now they're talking about gender
on twitter right
and i mean i remember i went to an aclu
event you know they were like
celebrating their anniversary they
didn't even have a free speech
like they didn't even talk about their
free speech they're just embarrassed by
it now
well they made a lot of money they made
a lot of money opposing donald trump
and this is why i've never been a big
fan of most non-profits because
they're corporations they care about
their bottom line they have customers
the customers i'll tell you this i think
i think nonprofits are actually
substantially more dangerous than
for-profits
in not every single one obviously but
there are good for-profits that do the
right thing that
are maybe sustainable and try to avoid
polluting and there are some good
non-profits that tend to be very small
and they actually want to help people
but here's what i found with most
nonprofits they are still just
corporations
the customer is an individual who wants
their hopes and dreams fulfilled or at
least wants to feel
like they're doing something non-profits
make money by convincing you
that you don't have to do anything you
don't got to change your life
you don't have to recycle you don't have
to go and fight for the rights of free
speech just give me 20 bucks and i'll do
it for you and then they don't
they don't but they want to make sure
their customers think
they're getting a product that's the
crazy thing with a for with a poor
profit like if we're selling pillows
like we actually have one's a burlap
sack full of packing peanuts
i actually have to give you a sack full
of packing peanuts
otherwise you're like yo where's my
product not the non-profits not aclu
and especially not the new york times
this is the crazy thing about the news
industry
if you call a plumber because your
toilet breaks right plumber comes in
fixes your toilet you walk over you
flush it it works
you say okay my toilet works here's your
money one day you call the plumber you
told us at work he says i fixed your
toilet
take my word for it you flush it nothing
happens you say bro
i'm not paying you how do you know the
new york times or any other news
organization is doing their job
how can you tell the article is the is
exactly what you asked for in terms of a
product legitimate information
you can't you can't check it i mean you
can only guess and i mean you can infer
from the fact that when they actually
report something that's in your area of
expertise it's wrong
right right right right right like you
kill me indonesia effects i mean that
key that keeps happening you just see
them report something
i remember i remember doing this i
remember i went to it was during the
flynn case and i went to a hearing
and you know watched how judge sullivan
handled the defendants and
you know came out of that hearing and i
was there and then i watched all the
news stations reported
wrong like it was just their their
description it was true in so far as
they weren't making
explicit factual errors but their like
entire description of it was super
misleading um that's how it is
during the last show we did when we did
super chat someone asked us this
question like how do we trust what we
read
and i went off on a tangent but one of
the things i said if it's an anonymous
source there's a lot of reason to be
skeptical
another thing you really have to ask
yourself when you're reading the news
whether it's even from independent or
mainstream media is who benefits
who benefits from this information and
ask yourself what this is
yeah with this new york times story it's
a you know a lot of independent critical
thinkers use that
term cubono especially when uh going
through
our modern news lexicon but with that
new york times story
cubono who benefits from that
psychological emotional
damage that was kind of sent out there
to the general public who benefits from
the story being perpetrated
that these ravaged savages beat someone
over the head and bashed their head in
until their skull exploded
with a fire extinguisher well it's who
benefits off of that the cabal
yeah no no no no i i don't know who the
cabal is but time magazine said
that there was a cobalt their words not
mine of wealthy elites
who were conspiring again time magazine
said they not me
to fortify the election well to ensure
the proper outcome
of course right and so who benefits well
the people who are trying to impeach
donald trump
i would normally just say the democrats
but apparently time magazine says
there's a cabal so yeah i guess it's
canon now
you know you know for a long time people
have referred to the cabal in a sort of
conspiratorial way
and people have been like oh come on
there's no cabal time magazine
an official certified news guard source
you can put in wikipedia now the cabal
and then put a little citation to the
time magazine article it exists
i'm half kidding by the way thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time